guten Abend liebe Zuschauer Mario Pohl
könnte bald fallen die Ostukraine
insgesamt steht kurz vor der nächsten
schweren russischen Offensive und in
Deutschland wächst im Angesicht dieses
vernichtungsfeldzuges die Verwirrung
womit half die Regierung den Ukrainern
bisher wirklich was wird man noch tun
und liefern was überhaupt nicht wer den
Erklärungsversuchen des Kanzlers folgt
weiß am Ende weniger als zuvor selbst
die Koalitionspartner werden offensiv
kritisch wo bleibt sie die versprochene
Zeitenwende des spd-bundeskanzlers Olaf
Scholz wir müssen reden mit diesen
Gästen
Sigmar Gabriel ehemaliger Vizekanzler
und Bundesaußenminister
die deutsch-ukrainerin Marina Weißmann
Brigadegeneral ade Erich Fahrt
die Sicherheitsexpertin Claudia major
und Roderich Kiesewetter CDU
Außenpolitiker sie sind zu Gast bei
Maybrit Illner
und unsere erste Küche heute Abend geht
nach Münster zu Marina weißband in Kiel
geboren nun in Münster zu Hause seit
acht Wochen Marina weißband müssen ihre
Freunde ihre Familie in der Ukraine in
Kiew diesen Krieg ertragen was glauben
Sie wie lange ist das noch durchzuhalten
auszuhalten
wir gehen im Moment alle davon aus dass
Putin eine Entscheidung zum 9 mai suchen
wird und das diese heiße Phase dieses
Krieges dann mehr oder weniger vorbei
sein wird die östlichen experten gehen
nicht davon aus dass dieser Krieg sich
in den Sommer ziehen wird ich gehe davon
aus dass der Konflikt dann einfriert und
das wird auf beiden Seiten große
Probleme geben je nachdem was die
Ukraine bis dahin erreichen kann was
Putin bis dahin erreichen kann weshalb
ich die Situation gerade so angespannt
verfolge und nochmal zu ihren Freunden
ihre Familie
ich bin gerade ihn gegenüber in einer
sehr sehr schwierigen Position weil ich
immer noch täglich telefoniere und ich
werde sehr sehr hart angeschnauzt warum
Deutschland nicht so hilft wie wir es
wie die anderen ist tun warum
Deutschland bremst ich versuche ihn zu
erklären ich versuche ihnen zu
versprechen dass Sie nicht vergessen
sind dass wir helfen aber ich bin selbst
sehr verwirrt von dem Vorgehen der
Regierung und
sagen wir wir machen uns gerade nicht
sehr beliebt die Leute haben sehr große
Angst davor wie der Konflikt eskalieren
kann und was die Ukraine bis dahin noch
alles verliert wenn Putin sie zur
Kapitulation zwingen will darüber werden
wir heute reden Claudia Meyer ist bei
uns sicherheits- und
verteidigungsexpertin Frau Meier dir 19
Mai ist ein besonderer Tag es ist der
Tag der Befreiung und auch die NATO
vermutet dass die russischen Truppen für
Putin zu diesem Tag einen Sieg
organisieren erzwingen
Herr Bomben müssen was wäre der Sieg
das war es gut in allein was der Sieg
wäre aber es müsste etwas sein was er
vorweisen kann und so wie es jetzt
aussieht geht es wahrscheinlich darum
die gesamten Oblast also die gesamte
Region des Don Bass denn jetzt und
Johannes zu kontrollieren möglicherweise
die Landbrücke bis rüber zu Krimi bis
auf mariupo jetzt schon kontrolliert und
damit zumindest einen Teilsieg vorweisen
kann das könnte eine Möglichkeit sein um
am 9 mai zu sagen wir haben den
Faschismus 1945 besiegt wir haben ihn
jetzt noch mal besiegt denn das ist ja
das narrativ was Putin zu Hause also in
Russland vorgibt was sagen sie wird
Putin eine Chance haben dieses Ziel zu
erreichen wir haben in den letzten
Kriegswochen gesehen dass vieles anders
war als wir vermutet haben und das
Waffenlieferung aus dem Westen wirklich
einen Unterschied machen können und
deshalb ist wirklich die Frage inwieweit
sich die westlichen Länder
jetzt engagieren die Ukraine mit
schweren Waffen unterstützen um sie
damit zu befähigen dieser großen
russischen Offensive etwas
entgegenzusetzen um das etwas
plastischer zu machen die Ukrainer steht
jetzt Russland in einem sehr großen Raum
gegenüber vielleicht können wir Sie noch
mal zeigen
und muss sich gegen russische 100
Kilometer Grenze muss ich gegen und auch
nicht mehr bis sie vorher hatten Häuser
Kämpfe beispielsweise oder Städte
sondern wirklich einen großen Raum und
muss sich gegen russische Luftangriffe
werden muss ich gegen russischer
Artillerie werden wenn sie dem
widerstehen wollen dann brauchen sie
schwere Ausrüstung wie Panzer wie
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge Flugabwehr
Artillerie und die Frage ist sind wir in
der Lage damit meine ich nicht nur uns
Deutsche sondern generell die westlichen
Staaten die Ukraine jetzt schnell zu
unterstützen aber und da gebe ich Frau
weißband recht wahrscheinlich läuft das
auf einen langfristigen meinetwegen auch
eingefrorenen Konflikt hinaus jetzt
schon zu überlegen was danach kommt also
aus diesem akuten wir müssen jetzt
helfen schon überlegen wie eigentlich
langfristig auch die Unterstützung sich
an also es hängt auch ein bisschen an
uns wie gut die Ukraine bestehen kann
und was für sie Putin am 9 mai
präsentieren kann Erich fatt sitzt neben
ihnen Brigadegeneral ade Herfahrt sie
haben auch bis 2013 Frau Bundeskanzlerin
Merkel beraten in diesen militär- und
verteidigungspolitischen fragen
in welcher Phase des Krieges sind wir
aus ihrer Sicht würden sie sich Frau
major anschließen und würden Sie sagen
dass wenn wir ihnen vom Ende her denken
wollen man jetzt als nächstes seitens
des Westens eigentlich was tun müsste
naja dass man den Konflikt vom Ende her
denken muss halte ich für sehr wichtig
und das passiert zu wenig ich meine wir
befinden uns in einer militärischen
eskalationsdebatte in Deutschland
Stichwort schwere Waffen und wir müssten
den Aktien gerade politisch viel stärker
setzen auf dem Zustand danach das heißt
auf den waffenstillcher auf die
friedensverhandlung die unter Umständen
dann erfolgen müssen was die schweren
Waffen anbelangt dieses Gelände auswärts
ist ein Japan ist natürlich ein offenes
Gelände ein Panzer günstiges Gelände
nicht aber schwere Waffen also
Kampfpanzer Schützenpanzer
Panzerhaubitzen zu liefern ist schon
eine eine Kategorie Waffen die die
anderen Bündnispartner so nicht liefern
die Amerikaner liefern Mannschaft
Transportwagen Feld Artillerie aber sie
liefern nicht ihren m one Abrahams und
auch nicht ihren Bradley und die Briten
auch nicht ihren Challenger also diese
Aufforderung an Deutschland Kampfpanzer
zu schicken ist ein anderes Ding und
erhöht die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass man
in der Wahrnehmung und auch faktisch
stark in die Rolle der Kriegspartei
rutscht das Wichtigste aber ist das
Kampfpanzer Schützenpanzer nur mehr zum
Zeitpunkt die Lieferung militärisch
unsinnig ist weil wir die
Ausbildungszeit nicht haben weil wir
Techniker mitschicken müssen eine
Logistikkette aufbauen müssen die
Ersatzteilversorgung sicherstellen und
auch den Transport und das ist ein
anderes Ding 100 Golf in die Ostukraine
zu fahren ist das eine aber 100
Kampfpanzer Leopard dazu verlegen auf
der Schiene das wird Russland niemals
zulassen das heißt diese Panzer werden
die Ostukraine nie erreichen diese
Panzer selbst wenn man nächste Woche ist
gelingt Herr Krise wird das Partei
Scholz zur Umkehr zu bewegen und sagen
jawohl wir liefern schwere Waffen es hat
keinerlei militärischer operativer
Relevanz für den laufenden Konflikt für
die nächsten Wochen und die nächsten
Monate das ist das was mich stört das
ist eigentlich eine Phantom Debatte die
wir führen dazu kommt die Bundeswehr
klar gesagt gestern noch der
stellvertretender Generalinspektor wir
haben keine schweren Waffen zur
Verfügung das ist erstmal ein Faktum was
dann auch rausnehmen muss es gibt zwei
Kollegen von ihnen Lothar Domröse sagt
der Unterschied zu den deutschen neueren
Panzern ist wie der zwischen Opel und
Golf und es ist kein Problem die
Kollegen da auszubilden Egon Rams sagt
kann man auch im Schnellkurs machen
hätten wir nur vor fünf Wochen schon
machen sollen irren die sich ja die
irren sich wirklich also ich schätze
beide Kollegen wie Kameraden sehr nicht
aber das geht eben nicht es geht ja auch
nicht nur um das Fahren sondern das ist
nehmen sie den Schützenpanzer Marder ist
es ein ganz komplexes Waffensystem da
sitzen Fahrer ein Richtschützen
Ladeschütze da gibt es einen hinteren
Kampfraum einen Kommandanten der eine 20
mm Kanone einsetzt eine Panzer Abwehr
Waffe hat die den abgesessenen Teil
führen muss dieser einzelne Panzer muss
sich bewegen in einem Zug in einer
Kompanie er muss das Gefecht der
verbundenen Waffen kennen mit allem drum
und dran das sind ausbildungsprozesse
die wirklich nicht in Tagen zu machen
sind ich meine man kann immer sagen hat
sie in der deutschen Militärgeschichte
immer gegeben eine Woche Ausbildung ab
an die Front das haben wir erlebt im 20
Jahrhundert aber kann er nicht
verantwortungsvoll sein also das geht
nicht okay wir sind das ist interessant
Frage natürlich nach Goslar zu Sigmar
Gabriel er ist uns zugeschaltet und war
Vizekanzler dieses Landes Außenminister
Umweltminister Wirtschaftsminister was
wir Herfahrt hier anführt sind die
Argumente der sozialdemokratischen
sozialdemokratisch geführten
Bundesregierung zunächst nicht schwere
Waffen einzusetzen und also vor allen
Dingen Panzer
würden Sie sagen Herr Gabriel mal ganz
offen gefragt dass dieses Land eines der
reichsten der Welt in Bezug auf die
geforderte Unterstützung alles tut was
möglich ist wirklich alles
bin ich dankbar dass wird generalfahrt
jemand da ist der wirklicher
Militärexperte ist ich hatte den letzten
Tagen und Wochen den Eindruck dass die
Zahl der selbsteinhaltlichen
Militärexperten ungefähr so schnell
gewachsen ist wie vorher die der Hobby
wäre loben wir gehen mit einer
Leichtigkeit mit dieser Frage um bei der
es ja am Ende darum geht ob wir einen
Konflikt erweitern oder ob wir ihnen
sozusagen stabilisieren können erweitern
heißt dass wir nicht nur die Ukraine
unterstützen sondern selbst
Kriegsteilnehmer werden und das will die
Nato nicht und offensichtlich ist es so
dass die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika
und Großbritannien jedenfalls das was
öffentlich von Deutschland gefordert
wird nämlich Kampfpanzer dorthin zu
schicken nicht tun und ich finde es gibt
eine relativ einfache Lösung für die
politische Debatte in Deutschland zu
sagen alles was die Vereinigten Staaten
und die NATO machen machen wir auch
und das was die nicht machen machen wir
auch nicht so jetzt ich finde es
überhaupt angemessen dass die
interessant ja dass sich seit zwei Tagen
auch die Berichterstattung dreht es sind
seit zwei Tagen Nachrichten am Markt
dass die US-Amerikaner auch schwere
Waffen in die Ukraine liefern die
Belgier und die hollersende Holländer
sind dazu bereit die Briten sind dazu
bereit die Frage ist Herr Kiesewetter
und damit sind wir bei unserem fünften
Gast heute ich am Tisch
die machen das offensichtlich es gibt
diese Unterstützung aus anderen
NATO-Staaten die Kanadier sollen auch
dabei sein
sind die Deutschen da mittlerweile
isoliert
ich möchte Gelegenheit auch wirklich
nutzen Herrn Gabriel und Herrn Fahrt
entschieden zu widersprechen
die Amerikaner unterstützen sehr massiv
mit 70 Haubitzen mit 140.000 Schuss Axel
remunition und das ist sehr viel das
wissen wir seit heute aber gestern
wussten wir bereits auch als Herr
Gabriel das Interview in Deutschlandfunk
gab wussten wir bereits dass die
Amerikaner 18 Haubitzen und 40.000
Geschosse liefern also da tut sich was
es bewegt sich etwas und ich Teile
überhaupt nicht die Auffassung von Herrn
Fahrt das ist hier jetzt um Eskalation
und eskalations Rhetorik geht russland
hat eskaliert die Ukraine steht vor dem
Zusammenbruch es geht darum dass die
Ukraine hier Werte verteidigt die wir
ihr verwehrt haben 1994 geben Sie
Atomwaffen ab 208 und 2014 hat die
Bundesregierung und der Kanzlerin Merkel
und Vizekanzler der SPD die Aufnahme in
die Nato und in die EU verhindert 218
den beitrittsplan verhindert das gab es
damals gute Gründe aber jetzt die
Ukraine die quasi um ihre Freiheit
kämpft weil sie zur EU und zur NATO
gehören will zu opfern ich habe den
Eindruck dass Teile der Sozialdemokratie
die UK schon aufgegeben haben und jetzt
geht es darum auch unsere Bevölkerung
deutlich zu machen das erwarte ich von
dem Bundeskanzler dass wir hier noch ein
Pfund drauf legen müssen wenn die
Niederländer wenn die Belgier wenn die
Amerikaner und die Briten schwere Waffen
liefern dann reicht ein Ringtausch mit
Slowenien nicht da haben wir mehr zu tun
und überher fahrt wir beide sind
konfirmierte Offiziere dieser Bundeswehr
ihr beide wissen dass dort keine
Buggyfahrer kommen sondern Leute die auf
erwiesenen erfahrenen Panzern und
gefechtsfahrzeugen der es Warschauer
Pakt des ausgebildet sind hier geht es
um alte Modelle hier geht es um das
Gefecht der verbundenen Waffen dass
diese Truppen beherrschen und zwar viel
besser als die Bundeswehr und dann
müssen wir uns einen Ruck geben und auch
unsere Bevölkerung sagen die Ukraine hat
jede Hilfe verdient denn nach der
Ukraine fällt Georgien fällt Moldau und
womöglich auch das Baltikum
wir kommen und gucken uns vielleicht
noch mal an was am Dienstag Olaf Scholz
der Bundeskanzler erklärte er wollte den
Versuch machen seine Entscheidungen zu
erklären ist ist aus der Wahrnehmung
vieler bei einem Versuch geblieben
auch in der neunten Kriegswoche bleibt
die Bundesregierung hart deutschland
will die Ukraine nicht direkt mit
Panzern beliefern
stattdessen soll es Ringen tausche mit
anderen NATO-Partnern geben und der
Kanzler verspricht Geld damit könne Kiew
von einer Lieferliste der deutschen
Industrie bestellen
die Ukraine hat sich nun von dieser
Liste eine Auswahl zu eigen gemacht und
wir stellen ihr das für den Kauf
notwendige Geld zur Verfügung diese
Entscheidung stößt auch bei den
ampelpartnern auf Kritik
meine Forderung ist erstmal und mein
Wunsch dass der Bundeskanzler sich jetzt
mal dafür ausspricht dass wir
grundsätzlich schwere Waffen liefern
Artillerie möglicherweise Panzer die
Zeit drängt der Krieg wartet nicht bis
wir uns sortiert haben angesichts der
bereits begonnen Offensive es
entscheidend das schwere Waffen schnell
geliefert werden die Gefahr ist umso
größer je länger der Krieg sich hinzieht
und je stärker die Ukraine in
bedrängnis-gerät auf Kritiker aus seiner
Koalition antwortet Olaf Scholz trotzig
manchem von diesen Jungs und Mädels muss
ich mal sagen weil ich nicht tue was ihr
wollt deshalb führe ich
[Applaus]
Marina beißband sie sind Mitglied der
Grünen nehmen sie dem Bundeskanzler
nehmen Sie diese Regierung ab dass sie
alles tut was in ihrer Macht steht oder
sagen Sie wie Herr Hofreiter dass das
Kanzleramt das Problem ist
sagen wir so ich habe sehr wenig
Überblick als Bürgerin wird mir sehr
wenig Möglichkeit geboten
nachzuvollziehen was Deutschland
tatsächlich tut aus allem was ich mir
zusammen recherchiert habe aus deutschen
und internationalen Quellen tut die
Regierung aber längst nicht alles was
sie kann ja wir haben Geld zwei
Milliarden gegen die 32 Milliarden die
wir dieses Jahr in Russland überwiesen
haben und von diesem Geld darf sich die
Ukraine aber keine schweren Waffen
kaufen da ist da wird der Export
blockiert von der also der die deutsche
Industrie darf das der Ukraine gar nicht
verkaufen und ich finde das sehr
paternalistisch das zu begründen mit ach
die Ukrainer können eh nicht damit
umgehen wenn Sie diese Waffen kaufen
wollen ich denke mal wenn Sie diese
Waffen kaufen wollen dann werden sie
wissen wofür sie brauchen aber ganz
grundlegend
ist mein Anliegen ich will Frieden okay
ich will Frieden für meine Familie in
der Ukraine ich will Frieden für meine
Familie in Deutschland und dann gucke
ich mir an was sichert Frieden Frieden
wird gesichert erstens durch ein starkes
Völkerrecht das starke Staaten davon
abhält schwache Staaten zu überfallen
weil sie wissen damit komme ich nicht
durch da gibt es Konsequenzen und damit
dieses Völkerrecht irgendwas wert ist
muss es verteidigt werden dafür muss die
Ukraine gewinnen das zweite was Frieden
sich hat ist ein einheitliches
geschlossenes Europa und ganz ehrlich
unsere europäischen Verbündeten sind
sauer auf uns die internationalen
Zeitungen schreiben schrecklich über
Deutschland kritisieren unsere Regierung
Mitglieder des Europaparlaments sind
verwirrt und
wissen überhaupt nichts mit unserer
Reaktion anzufangen das heißt wenn ich
Frieden will dann muss Deutschland
beides erreichen und ich verstehe nicht
und habe von dieser Bundesregierung noch
nicht die Antwort auf eine ganz
grundlegende Frage gehört will die
Bundesregierung dass die Ukraine diesen
Krieg gewinnt denn Herr Scholz sagt in
seiner Ansprache die Ukraine müsse sich
erwehren aber er sagte nicht sie muss
sich e aktiver wären und er sagte auch
nicht sie muss gewinnen wir geben nach
Goslar Sigmar Gabriel das sind zwei
zentrale Fragen wenn ich mich recht
erinnere hat Olaf Scholz gesagt Putin
darf diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen aber er
hat nicht gesagt die Ukraine sollte
diesen Krieg gewinnen warum nicht
ich weiß ja nicht ein bisschen viel in
die Sprache von ein Scholz hinein
interpretieren klar ist doch dass
Deutschland wie alle anderen Europäer
die Nato will dass die Ukraine sich
verteidigten zwar erfolgreich im vorhin
über die Frage gesprochen wo endet das
ich glaube nicht dass wenn Russland der
Überzeugung ist es habe jetzt im Donbass
seine Ziele erreicht dass dieser Krieg
endet ich glaube dass das weitergehen
wird vielleicht nicht in der gleichen
Massivität aber die Ukraine wird nicht
aufgeben und worum es glaube ich gehen
wird ist eine sehr lange Unterstützung
der Ukraine auf allen Ebenen auch mit
militärischen Mitteln um sozusagen
jedenfalls sich dort an der Linie an der
möglicherweise dieser brutale krieg
jetzt stoppt dann aber auf Dauer zu
verteidigen ich glaube wir werden eher
sowas wie ein immer wieder aufbrechenden
frozen Konflikt erleben das zweite ist
ich finde wir müssen ein bisschen
aufpassen dass wir uns nicht gegenseitig
Dinge unterstellen die wir nicht gesagt
haben ich habe vorhin nicht über schwere
Waffen geredet na klar braucht die
Ukraine schwere Waffen ich habe darüber
die Frage geredet warum eigentlich die
us Kommentar und Großbritannien keine
Panzer liefern offensichtlich weil sie
der Überzeugung sind dass das eine
Eskalation herbeiführen kann die die
Vereinigten Staaten die Nato und
Großbritannien nicht wollen natürlich
will die Ukraine dass wir stärker
eintreten in diesen Konflikt das
verstehe ich auch aber die Entscheidung
der NATO und des Westens ist wir
unterstützen aber wir wollen nicht
Kriegsteilnehmer sein und die letzte
Bemerkung
ich bin jetzt nicht derjenige der jedes
Wort das dort gesprochen worden ist
verstanden hat aber eins ist doch mal
klar in Deutschland entscheidet nicht
der Bundeskanzler über den Export das
wissen auch die Beteiligten Abgeordneten
sondern der Bundessicherheitsrat und
wenn die Grünen und die FDP nicht
zufrieden sind mit dem was der Kanzler
macht dann müssen sie im
Bundessicherheitsrat andere
Entscheidungen herbeiführen das jetzt
sozusagen getan wird als sei das alles
eine Einzelentscheidung von der Scholz
natürlich Unsinn erfahrt hat diesen
Bundessicherheitsrat genau wie ich
angehört und deswegen finde ich die die
beste Linie wäre und da gebe ich bin ich
auch etwas ratlos warum das nicht
öffentlich passiert ist in der NATO und
mit den USA abgestimmt dass jeder das
bringt was die Ukraine benötigt und was
die NATO für verantwortbar hält dabei
muss Deutschland dabei sein und auch
offen legen dass sie dieser Rolle der
NATO und den Vereinigten Staaten folgt
nochmal wenn sie noch mal alles was die
USA machen können wir auch machen alles
was die USA nicht machen sollten wir
auch die Finger von lassen können Sie
noch mal erklären warum sie denken dass
Olaf Scholz eben ja ausgesprochen eine
Liste sogar von allen schweren Waffen
befreit hat wenn diese Berichterstattung
korrekt ist die der Ukraine vorgelegt
wurde und nicht dazu gesagt hat dass die
entscheidenden schweren Waffen von
dieser Liste genommen wurden warum er
also offensichtlich auf gar keinen Fall
schwere Waffen und wenn dann nur über
Bande in die Ukraine schicken möchte was
ist der Grund dafür
ist sehr Grund dafür dass er Angst davor
hat das atomare also das ist die die
berühmten taktischen atomarischen
atomaren Waffen zum Einsatz kommen was
ist der Grund dass er da so
zurückhaltend
ich kann nicht für den Bundeskanzler
sprechen und ich bin nicht mal mehr im
Parlament das einzige was ich verstanden
habe ist dass er seine Entscheidungen
abstimmt mit dem Weißen Haus und das
offensichtlich diese Entscheidung
gemeinschaftlich getroffen worden ist
ich hoffe jedenfalls dass ich das
richtig verstanden habe dass natürlich
eine schmaler Grad da ist bei dem alle
versuchen alles zu tun was die Ukraine
braucht aber trotzdem nicht selbst
Kriegspartei werden wollen dass das ganz
schwierig ist das verstehe ich aber ich
würde erwarten dass der deutsche
Bundeskanzler das ich kann mich nur
wiederholen mit dem Weißen Haus und mit
der NATO verabredet tut und entlang
dieser entlang dieser Kriterien dann
allerdings auch liefert so und übrigens
noch mal ich glaube nicht dass das
schnell zu Ende ist wir werden wir
werden über lange Zeit die Ukraine
unterstützen müssen denn das was wir da
erleben werden ist ja kein Frieden wenn
wir Glück haben dann ist es ein
Waffenstillstand nicht mal das glaube
ich denn die Ukraine kann nicht einfach
ein Teil ihres Territoriums einen Putin
verschenken ich glaube dass das nicht
passieren wird interessante These da
kommen wir noch hinzu Herr Kiesewetter
bleiben wir erst bei dem was hier am
Tisch und von unseren Gästen geschaltet
aus Goslar und aus Münster gesagt wurde
die US-Amerikaner die Briten liefern
keine Panzer warum sollen wir dann
Panzer liefern und reden die ganze Zeit
über Leopard und Marder ist dieses
Argument richtig also hier muss man sehr
sorgfältig auf die Dialektik achten es
ging um schwere Waffen und Artillerie
zählt natürlich zu schweren Waffen und
über Kampfpanzer Leopard wurde sehr früh
gesprochen dass das nicht möglich ist
das teile ich auch aber Schützenpanzer
Marder sind möglich und jetzt geben wir
plötzlich 90 Schützenpanzer Marder an
Slowenien um dann von dort aus alte
sowjetisches Material einen Kampfpanzer
zu liefern und wir liefern dafür
Schützenpanzer warum dann nicht gleich
direkt aber ich möchte noch mal den
Punkt von Herrn Gabriel aufgreifen sie
leiten die Atlantikbrücke ich bin
Mitglied bei Ihnen wie wäre es denn mit
einer gemeinsamen transatlantischen
Initiative wie wir die Ukraine
unterstützen können ich glaube sie haben
da ganz viel Verantwortung und als
Atlantikbrücke könnten wir auch
konstruktiv mitwirken denn die
Amerikaner haben ja auch ein
Paradigmenwechsel hinter sich beiden
kann sich nicht einen weiteren
verlorenen Krieg leisten und es geht
schlichtweg darum dass die Ukraine
diesen Krieg nicht verliert und das
Putin ihn nicht gewinnt und das Ziel
muss doch sein dass wir das Machbare da
bin ich bei Herrn Gabriel das Machbare
liefern und da wäre eine Initiative der
Atlantikbrücke sicherlich hilfreich auch
damit wir besser auf beide Bevölkerungen
einwirken dass wir wirklich erläutern
worum es hier geht aber schwere Waffen
war das Thema und nicht Kampfpanzer okay
also gleich nochmal zurück dieser
Gedanke Sigmar gab aber sie sind der
Chef der Atlantikbrücke das ist ein
Verein ein internationaler Verein der
sich mit Außen- und
sicherheitspolitischen Fragen befasst
könnten Sie sich das vorstellen dass
auch von der Atlantikbrücke eine solche
Initiative ausginge dann wüssten man wer
und wie sehr die Partner abgestimmt sind
untereinander
Tatsache dass sie Recht haben dass wir
ein Verein sind tun wir das natürlich
reden wir mit unseren amerikanischen
Freunden das ist ja der Grund warum ich
dafür plädiere dass ich Deutschland mal
rausbegibt aus der Rolle dass wir immer
erklären was wir machen sondern mit den
Amerikanern gemeinschaftlich erklären
was wir gemeinsam tun können das alles
machen wir in der Atlantikbrücke aber
wir sind dann Vereinen ich fände dass
zum Beispiel wenn im Bundestag über die
Frage redet wird was da beschlossen wird
dann kann man erstens das auch
beantragen und zweitens noch mal die
Koalition sitzt im Bundessicherheitsrat
gemeinsam mit SPD FDP und Grünen warum
ist das keine Leitlinie für die deutsche
Politik zu sagen was die Vereinigten
Staaten und die NATO tun machen wir mit
und dort findet die Abstimmung über die
Frage statt was für liefern und was wir
nicht liefern denn dann haben wir glaube
ich eine klare Haltung so das ist ein
Vorschlag eines Sozialdemokraten wir
haben keinen grünen und keinen
FDP-Politiker heute hier bei uns in der
Runde interessanterweise protestiert ja
aber in Teilen die FD Idee die Grünen
sind mit einer anderen vehement am Start
Frau bärbock sagt heute natürlich wird
es auch schwere Waffen und Lieferungen
von schweren Waffen geben das ist bei
uns kein Tabu auch wenn es in der
deutschen Debatte manchmal so klingt das
war ihre Äußerung heute vom Tag wir sind
noch mal Frau Meier bei der Frage und
die ist entscheidend sind die Länder der
NATO sind die Partner Länder der NATO
untereinander abgestimmt kann man these
Sigmar Gabriel davon ausgehen dass wir
mit unseren NATO-Partnern
Arbeitsweisen Konzentrationen
abgesprochen haben und ein deutscher
Beitrag abgestimmt ist mit unseren
NATO-Partnern
ich würde auch mal Schritt zurückgehen
und wird auf das letzte nato-treffen
Anfang des Monats gehen und da gab es
eine klare Entscheidung die der
Generalsekretär danach verkündet hat und
die war
die NATO möchte nicht selbst
Kriegspartei werden das hat er Herr
Gabriel eben gesagt an dieser roten
Linie hat sich nichts verändert weil da
das Risiko gesehen wird dass man in
einen Krieg mit Russland reingezogen
wurde der eine ganz andere
katastrophenlevel erreicht wurde als
jetzt aber unterhalb dieser roten Linie
die sich nicht verändert hat hat sich
die NATO massiv bewegt sie hat nämlich
gesagt alle Alliierten sind sich einig
dass sie jetzt auch schweres Material
liefern wollen und dass sie auch
westliches Material liefern wollen bis
dahin war immer der Ansatz zu sagen
schweres ist uns zu heikel das ist
gekippt also die NATO haben starten und
gemeinsam erklärt sie wollen schweres
Material liefern und die zweite die
zweite Punkt war zu sagen wir liefern
eigentlich nur alte sowjetisches
Material weil das können Sie direkt
bedienen und jetzt haben die naturtaten
gesagt nein wir sind auch bereit
westliches Material zu liefern
wenn wir jetzt gucken was die anderen
NATO starten machen die technotherapie
hat alte Panzer Außerirdischer Bauart
geliefert Panzer was jetzt geplant ist
im Rahmen dieses Ringtausch ist das auch
noch mal Panzer geliefert werden
die Amerikaner liefern Haubitzen andere
liefern
wir dann möglicherweise ausbilden werden
wenn das unsere Nato-Partner sind dann
wären wir ja in sehr guter Gesellschaft
wenn wir uns auch durchringen könnten
beispielsweise gepanzerte Fahrzeuge zu
liefern jetzt höre ich schon kommt das
Argument wir sind aber blank das hat der
Inspekteur des Heeres gesagt das hat
auch der stellvertretende
Generalinspektor genau erlaubenthal die
Frage ist ich glaube wir müssen noch mal
ein Schritt zurückgehen müssen sagen
warum unterstützen wir die Ukraine Frau
Weißmann hat das hervorragend erklärt
ich glaube wir müssen auch vom Ende her
denken wir müssen sagen die Ukraine wenn
wir Sie unterstützen dann ist das
moralische Unterstützung es ist aber
auch weil die Ukraine für unsere
sicherheitspolitischen Interessen kämpft
wir wollen nicht in einem Europa leben
wo sich ein Angriffskrieg lohnt und wenn
wir sagen also unsere Unterstützung kann
dafür sorgen dass die Ukraine diesen
Krieg gewinnt oder das Russland ihn
nicht gewinnt wenn Russland diesen
Angriffskrieg gewinnen würde wäre die
sicherheitspolitische Lage in Europa und
wäre die eskalationsgefahr für uns NATO
starten um einiges höher als jetzt und
die sagen die die Lehre die Russland aus
gewonnenen Krieg in der Ukraine ziehen
könnte wäre zu sagen ein Krieg lohnt
sich ich kann mit Angriffskriegen meine
Interessen durchsetzen das hat in
Georgien 2008 funktioniert es hat 2014
in der Ukraine funktioniert in Syrien es
hat 2022 noch mal funkt sie hat ein
bisschen gedauert aber im Endeffekt hat
das funktioniert und dieses Szenario
möglich genau und dieses Szenario wollen
wir uns nicht vorstellen wenn wir vom
Ende her denken das heißt es ist
wirklich noch mal in unserem Interesse
sicherzustellen dass Russland diesen
Angriffskrieg nicht gewinnt und dann
letzte Gedanke ich das mal ausführen
darf dann natürlich der wenn der Geld
stellvertretende Generalinspektor sagt
wir sind blank dann ist es so Punkt aber
dann müssen wir vielleicht noch mal
sagen wenn das wirklich eine so
fundamentale Frage ist von der wir
stellen müssen wir da nicht die Abwägung
neu treffen und müssen überlegen
vielleicht
reden wir mit unseren Partnern in der
NATO und in der EU vor allen Dingen in
der NATO und sagen vielleicht können wir
aus der umlaufreserve der Marder doch
noch was nehmen vielleicht sagen wir
Landes- und bündnisverteidigung ist
unsere Kernaufgabe da müssen wir als
Nato-Partner liefern aber wenn wir mit
den NATO-Partnern reden und sagen
Priorität hat jetzt die Ukraine wäre das
für euch okay dass wir möglicherweise
kleine Abstriche machen ist das eine
politische Frage die wir mit den
NATO-Partnern besprechen müssen und die
dann im Endeffekt die Regierung treffen
muss aber wenn wir wirklich einig sind
das Russland diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen
darf und das unser
sicherheitspolitisches Interesse ist das
ist diesen Krieg nicht gewinnt dann
müssen wir glaube ich andere Abwägungen
treffen und müssen wenigstens anders
kommunizieren und vielleicht auch ein
anderes Angebot machen an die noch mal
die Frage Herfahrt Völkerrechtsbruch der
sich lohnt den wir nicht aufhalten den
wir 2008 nicht aufgehalten haben
nachträglich in der Krim nicht
aufgehalten haben
sie haben in einem Interview und da muss
man sehr fair sein das war Anfang
Februar gesagt dass sie glauben und
befürchten dass wenn wir da schwere
Waffen hinliefern würden das dann die
Gefahr eines Weltkrieges größer würde
weil Putin das als Provokation verstehen
muss heute sagen ganz viele Politiker
das glatte Gegenteil sie sagen wenn wir
da nicht schwere Waffen hinliefern dann
wird dieser Krieg endlos weitergehen und
dann kommen wir in einen dritten
Weltkrieg wie kann das sein dass wir
so dir also diametrale dissonante
Einschätzungen haben
ich glaube wichtig ist jetzt von der
politischen Seite her nicht zu sagen wir
wollen den Sieg der Ukraine wir wollen
den Ukraine helfen das ist richtig und
wir unterstützen Sie auch massiv na ich
aber ich muss sagen vom NDR denken heißt
für mich nicht ein militärischer Sieg
einer Seite in diesem Konflikt sondern
ein baldiges Ende dieses Konfliktes wie
immer geartet mit einer politischen
Lösung mich stört es wenn deutsche
Politiker von den Grünen
militärische Lösung als ultimatives Ziel
darstellen das ist doch verrückt und das
machen Politiker die mit Militär nichts
am Hut hatten die den Wehrdienst
verweigert haben die von der Bundeswehr
nichts wissen das geht doch nicht nicht
der Zustand muss so sein am Ende dass
wir wieder in einen wie immer gearteten
Waffenstillstand kommen und dazu gehört
dass wir irgendwann diesen Krieg beenden
und nicht auf Sieg setzen das ist ja ein
eine Rhetorik die nicht geht einfach in
der modernen Konfliktforschung ist das
ein echtes Novum und zum man muss jetzt
auch
an den Verhandlungstisch zwingen oder
glauben sie da geht der entspannten und
wird sich von uns überreden lassen nein
das wird er nicht machen ich wir werden
deswegen helfen ja auch der Ukraine das
ist ja auch in Ordnung und wir müssen
Ihnen auch helfen ich sag nur der Ansatz
muss ein anderer sein wir müssen
möglichst schnell aus dem Konflikt raus
wir können den zentral Europa keinen
Stellvertreter Krieg auf Jahre
gebrauchen der das Potenzial hat zu
einem nuklear-krieg zu eskalieren weil
Russland ist nicht Serbien ist nicht
Irak ist nicht Afghanistan ist nicht
Libyen nicht
Russland ist eine nuklearwarf macht mit
den meisten Nuklearwaffen weltweit das
ist ein Unterschied und da müssen wir
vorsichtig sein mit Waffenlieferungen
und vor allen Dingen mit unserer
kriegsrettorik und vor allen Dingen mit
einer Rhetorik die sagt wir setzen auf
dem militärischen Sieg einer Seite das
ist ein Fehler vom Ansatz her ist das
ein Fehler wir sind türkise Wetter sie
müssen uns helfen bei der Auflösung
dieses beschriebenen
dissonanten Bildes warum ist und es wird
immer der dritte Weltkrieg genommen und
es wird mit der atomaren macht natürlich
argumentiert logisch weil offensichtlich
unter dieser abtumaren Macht Putins eben
ist auch nicht möglich ist anders zu
reagieren sie haben mal in einem
Interview gesagt wenn der keine
Atomwaffen hätten dann werden wir längst
in der Ukraine ja jetzt hat er die aber
also da kann man ja irgendwie auch nur
sagen das ist leider so das ist
bedauernswert wem würden Sie sich
anschließen sie schließen sich
offensichtlich Anton Hofreiter an sie
schließen sich anderen Kollegen der FDP
an sie sagen wir müssen diese schweren
Waffen liefern um einen dritten
Weltkrieg zu verhindern auf jeden Fall
haben sich einige meiner Argumentation
angeschlossen die ich seit zwei Jahren
habe weil ich gesagt habe es kommt ein
Krieg auf uns zu und im Januar ist es ja
ganz offensichtlich geworden ich möchte
mich mal in die Lage eines ukrainischen
Abgeordneten versetzen oder eine
ukrainischen Abgeordnete mit der ich
erst unlängst sprach wenn die hört dass
die Ukraine nicht gewinnen darf und dass
man keine Kriegsrhetorik braucht dann
müssen wir mal uns mal das der
Hunderttausenden anschauen heute kam die
neuesten Zahlen 12,5 Millionen
Flüchtlinge davon 7 Millionen
siebeneinhalb Millionen innerhalb des
Landes 5 Millionen außerhalb und wir
sprechen davon dass die Ukraine nicht
militärisch gewinnen soll das halte ich
für fatal auch als Eindruck in diese
Bevölkerung das befördert ja geradezu
die flüchtlingswege aus dem Land und es
treibt Putin dahin den Krieg auch noch
mal militärisch zu eskalieren ich
befürchte dass wir gerade mit so einer
Rhetorik den Einsatz von taktischen
Nuklearwaffen herbeiführen weil Putin
sieht der Westen wird nichts tun und er
kann das mal praktisch erproben was in
der Militärdoktrin seit 2015 drin ist
also ich bedauere zutiefst dass wir mit
so einer Rhetorik auch in der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung wahrgenommen
werden ich bin ganz klar dafür dass wir
jetzt weil dieser Krieg nur militärisch
gewonnen werden kann dass wir natürlich
vom Ende her denken aber vom Ende her
denken heißt Sicherheitsgarantien für
die Ukraine die belastbar sind nämlich
eine Mitgliedschaft in der Europäischen
Union oder zumindest der Artikel der die
diese Sicherheitsversprechen beinhaltet
und zweitens eine Perspektive in die
Europäische Union und drittens damit das
bewirkt wird das Russland sehr klar
erkennt der Westen ist bereit die
Ukraine konventionell zu verteidigen wir
sind doch schon Partei und ich hoffe
dass wir auch parteiisch auf der Seite
der Ukraine stehen wir wollen nur nicht
mit Personal eingreifen aber das
Völkerrecht lässt zu dass wir Waffen
Munition Ausbildung alles leisten und
wir reizen das Völkerrecht hier nicht
aus sondern überlassen es in der
Rhetorik sogar denjenigen die sagen die
Ukraine soll sich mal nicht so haben
12,5 Millionen Menschen auf der Flucht
ja sollen wir denen sagen ihr habt keine
Aussicht kommt bitte alle zu uns wir
müssen ihn doch deutlich machen ihr habt
eine Chance diesen Krieg zu gewinnen und
wir tun alles um euch dabei zu helfen
sie unterstellen
insofern war darf ich bitte auf ein
Fahrt antworten sie dürfen gleich
antworten ich wollte eine Frage noch
hinterher Stellen gleich sind wir in
Münster sie unterstellen Olaf Scholz
tatsächlich dass er
aus diesem Grund einen Atomkrieg zu
verhindern sich so verhält wie er sich
verhält und sie befürchten dass wir
damit dem Ansehen Deutschlands in der
Welt Schaden ich glaube der Atomkrieg
ist wahrscheinlicher wenn wir der
Ukraine nicht helfen zweitens der
Bundeskanzler hat eine Zeitenwende
versprochen und er läuft jetzt Gefahr
und das sage ich jetzt als
staatspolitisch denkender Mensch er
läuft Gefahr dass das simple Rhetorik
bleibt dass ihr auf halber Strecke
stehen bleibt er wird ja getrieben von
FDP und Grünen weil Teile der
SPD-Fraktion nicht hinter der
Zeitenwende stehen und deshalb glaube
ich es auch sehr sinnvoll dass wir als
Union das auch die anderen Parteien die
die Regierung tragen dass wir jetzt
nicht uns auf den Kanzler einschießen
sondern dem Kanzler die Möglichkeit
geben diese zeitenwände auch praktisch
umzusetzen indem sie diese Abstimmung
nächste Woche anbieten nicht nur eine
Abstimmung anbieten sondern damit der
Kanzler auch sieht ein Großteil der
gewählten Abgeordneten des Bundestages
steht hinter der massiven militärischen
Unterstützung der Ukraine und steht
dafür dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg
nicht verliert sie wissen schon dass das
auch das Ende der Ampel sein könnte weil
wenn die Stimmung des Bundestages ohne
die SPD erreichten das glaube ich nicht
und natürlich stehen wir auch als Union
bereit zu unterstützen aber entscheiden
ist jetzt dass diese Regierung ihre
Mehrheiten hat und das Olaf Scholz doch
mal besser erklärt denn wenn die USA
massiv militärisch unterstützen die
Niederländer die Belgier dann darf er
nicht dahinter zurückbleiben und Listen
zusammenstreichen lassen die ich kenne
ich kenne die Listen wo drauf steht was
die Ukraine gefordert hat und das wird
einfach von der Liste genommen das ist
unredlich und auch diplomatisch
fragwürdig wir sind in Münster
ich möchte gerne auf das antworten was
Herford gesagt hat die Ukraine darf
diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen
was passiert ist ist dass Russland mit
seiner Armee in der Ukraine
einmarschiert ist und dort jetzt gerade
ein Völkermord verübt in Boccia sind
während der russischen Besetzung ein
Fünftel der verbliebenen Bürger getötet
worden Zivilisten die ermordet wurden es
werden systematisch Frauen vergewaltigt
und das passiert in allen Gebieten die
Russisch besetzt sind ein Sieg der
Ukraine sieht wie aus nicht dass die
Ukraine Russland erobert sondern einfach
nur dass die russische Armee sich hinter
die Grenzen der Ukraine zurückzieht das
ist ein ukrainischer Sieg dass sie sich
zurückzieht und dass die Ermordung von
Zivilisten beendet wird darf das
wirklich nicht unser Ziel sein muss das
nicht unser Ziel sein wer sind wir
ich muss erstmal korrigieren ich habe
nicht gesagt die Ukraine darf nicht
gewinnen sondern ich habe gesagt
politischer angucken muss sein diesen
Konflikt bald möglichst zu beenden das
ist ein anderer Ansatz und das was sie
schildern Frau Weißmann das bedrückt
mich auch sehr das sind ja Bilder aus
den Kriegen die wir kennen wir kennen
diese Bilder aus dem Irak aus
Afghanistan aus Syrien aus Libyen es ist
nichts Neues was dort passiert so
grausam das ist aber wir hatten wenn
denken Sie nur an den Irakkrieg wir
hatten da ein zigfaches an Opfern auch
zivilen Opfern das ist eben eine
Erscheinungsform moderner Konflikte die
man einfach sehen muss das ist
dramatisch das ist schlimm und ich
möchte das auch nicht gesund beten was
die Russen gemacht haben und ich bin
auch kein putinversteher aber es gibt
mir darum dass unser politischer
Anspruch sein muss diesen Konflikt
diesen Krieg baldmöglich zu beenden und
in Verhandlungen zu gehen und nicht in
eine in einem Lied ja natürlich
indem man nein wir stärken wir stärken
die ukrainische Seite politisch
militärisch finanziell nicht die
Bundesregierung hat ein Paket entworfen
ist eine Milliarde mit denen auch die
Ukraine selber Waffen kaufen kann ich
bin sicher übrigens dass der ukrainische
generalstaatschef sein Präsidenten nicht
vorschlagen wird von diesen Milliarden
Panzer zu kaufen vergessen Sie es nicht
und ich muss eins noch sagen als
Staatsbürger was mich sehr bedrückt ist
der Umgang der Ukraine mit Deutschland
und auch das Agieren des Botschafters in
Deutschland ich finde es nicht in
Ordnung und das stört mich auch ein
bisschen dass das nicht ausgesprochen
wird in Deutschland dass das nicht
thematisiert wird es ist nicht sehr
schön
vielleicht nehmen wir uns dann an dieser
Stelle dann doch noch mal die Zeit weil
es ja auch die letzte Woche bestimmt hat
dass es diese Äußerungen gab und es
einen Politiker gab der
versucht hat zu protestieren gegen
Äußerungen von anderen Melnik dem
ukrainischen Botschafter es wird
natürlich auf der anderen Seite auch
immer deutlicher wie tief führende
Sozialdemokraten und wichtige
Sozialdemokraten mit Putins Russland
verbunden dabei waren
viele Jahre waren die Drähte der SPD
nach Moskau gut
Sozialdemokraten kamen gern
wird Ihnen die russlandfreundliche
Politik jetzt zum Verhängnis
selbst Frank-Walter Steinmeiers Besuch
in Kiew wurde zuletzt abgelehnt
ich war dazu bereit aber offenbar und
ich muss zur Kenntnis nehmen war das in
Kiew nicht gewünscht ein diplomatischer
Affront in hitzigen Zeiten
ukraines Botschafter andre Melnik
kritisiert Steinmeier habe als Minister
seit Jahrzehnten ein Spinnennetz der
Kontakte mit Russland geknüpft und
schieb den Bundespräsidenten damit in
die Ecke der putinfreunde
Ex-Außenminister Sigmar Gabriel erwidert
das sei wahrheitswidrig und bösartig
angesichts Steinmeiers Einsatz für den
Frieden in der Ukraine
dabei haben sich Sozialdemokraten wie
Sigmar Gabriel und auch Manuela Schwesig
jahrelang für gute Kontakte und
Geschäfte mit Russland eingesetzt
Beispiel Nord Stream 2 jetzt heißt es
zurückrudern mit dem Wissen von heute
war die Unterstützung für nordstream 2
und die Stiftung ein Fehler und auch ich
habe diesen Fehler gemacht
es war ein Fehler bei den Einwänden
gegenüber Nord Stream 2 nicht auf die
Osteuropäer zu hören das war auch mein
Fehler
[Musik]
willkommen gleich noch mal zu dem
Spinnennetz von dem der ukrainische
Botschaft der Melnik sprach die Namen
der Politiker der SPD sind genannt
Steinmeier Schröder Frau Schwesig auch
sie sie haben sich jetzt nach dem
Bundespräsidenten auch entschuldigt für
die eine oder andere
Fehleinschätzung wer denken sie müsste
sich noch entschuldigen
ich habe mich nicht entschuldigt okay
ja das haben wir unter anderem gemacht
die Sendung ist zu kurz dafür und zu
erklären was eigentlich dazu geführt hat
dass wir die Abhängigkeit von russischem
Erdgas so weit getrieben haben es hat
auch viel damit zu tun dass wir in
Europa die Energiepolitik liberalisiert
haben dass die Märkte das angeblich
alles regeln sollten und dass wir damit
gemacht haben was wogegen ich mich
gewehrt habe ist der Eindruck den Herr
Melnik entwickelt hat dass der
Bundespräsident der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland quasi der
Interessenvertreter Russlands gewesen
sein das ist wirklich eine
Unverschämtheit es gibt niemanden der
sich in der Ukraine so sehr eingesetzt
hat wie Frank Steinmeier unter oder
vielleicht mit Angela Merkel gemeinsam
niemand zu die das so stark gemacht
haben der damalige ukrainische Präsident
poroschenko hat die deutsche
Bundesregierung gebeten im Jahr 2014 als
er unmittelbar vor einer militärischen
Niederlage gegen Russland stand ob sich
die deutsche Bundesregierung eingreifen
können um sozusagen über diese
Entwicklung von Minsker Verträgen ein
Zustand herbeizuführen um die wir jetzt
Ringen nämlich das den Stillstand von
Waffen wir sind wieder da wo wir damals
waren und das hat Angela Merkel und hat
Frankfurter Steinmeier getan ich selber
bin ganz häufig nach Russland Gefahren
warum na weil es unter anderem um die
Frage ging wie wir eigentlich absichern
können dass das Erdgas weiter durch die
trans-ukrainische Pipeline kommt und
dass die Erdgasversorgung der Ukraine
nicht mehr von Russland abhängt wir
haben heute eine Situation seit 2016 bei
der die Ukrainer bei uns das erdgasten
kaufen das ursprünglich aus Russland
kommt und haben sozusagen die
Absicherung der Ukraine wahrgenommen die
bis heute funktioniert das jetzt
sozusagen als Geschäftemacherei für
Russland zu diskreditieren ist unfassbar
ich meine Unterschied ob man politische
Fehleinschätzungen gemacht hat was soll
ich erklären das war eine Zeit in der
sie insgesamt 16 mal gereist sind und
sie sagen sie haben gemeinsam mit
Steinmeier erwirkt dass die Ukraine noch
heute Zahlungen bekommt für die
Gaslieferungen die
erklären sie 2014 hatte der russische
Präsident 2014 hat er der russische
Präsident und insbesondere seinen Chef
von Gazprom Herr Miller nicht nur die
Absicht durch Nord Stream 2 die
trans-ukrainische Pipeline zu ersetzen
sondern insgesamt kein Erdgas mehr zu
liefern vielleicht erinnern Sie sich
damals gab es Schlagzeilen über den
bevorstehenden Winter dass die
Erdgasversorgung der Ukraine nicht
gesichert ist es mussten Verträge
jeweils jedes Jahr neu verhandelt worden
und da sind wir in der Tat und zwar Frau
Merkel Herr Steinmeier und ich gemeinsam
immer wieder nach Russland und auch in
Deutschland mit Leuten von Gazprom
zusammengetreten um Lösungen dafür zu
finden dass die Erdgasversorgung weiter
durch diese Pipeline geht und am Ende ab
2016 ist dann die Lösung gefunden worden
das nennt sich reverse Flow dass die
Ukraine bei uns das Erdgas kaufen dass
sie brauchen und nicht mehr bei Russland
aber im Kern handelt es sich natürlich
weiter um russisches Erdgas solche
komplizierten Prozesse damals zu machen
in einer Situation in der damals schon
die Frage stand ob der Krieg sich
ausweitet heute zu diskreditieren nach
dem Motto jeder der mit Russland geredet
hat ist schuld an diesem Krieg das doch
Wahnsinn Herr Vater hat doch völlig
recht wir werden doch an einen Punkt
kommen an dem wir wieder reden müssen
über die Frage wie verhindern wir die
Fortsetzung von Gewalt davon sind wir
leider glaube ich weit entfernt aber
diese Debatte jeder der mal mit den
Russen geredet hat ist jetzt gleich kurz
davor Kriegsverbrecher zu sein immer das
doch hahnenbüchen Herr Gabriel hier ist
die Frage man kann der Bundesregierung
damals und den amtierenden Ministern
damals natürlich die Frage stellen dass
das ja nicht eine einmalige Situation
war sondern das offensichtlich über
Jahre eine Abhängigkeit von Putin und
von Moskau nicht nur hingenommen sondern
auch ausgeweitet wurde in den Herr Putin
das glatte Gegenteil von dem Tat wie was
für eine europ sehr zufriedensordnung
nennen Bernd Ulrich von der Zeit stellt
heute die gute Frage hätte den
Politikern nicht auffallen müssen dass
zu diesem Pathos mit dem man unterwegs
war ob unserer tollen russischen Drähte
immer auch Profit gehörte also hat es
sie nicht verwirrt dass das auch immer
unheimlich tolle Geschäfte waren
jedenfalls die unheimlich tollen
Geschäfte hat die deutsche Wirtschaft
gemacht nachdem in der im Jahr 2002 in
Europa beschlossen wurde dass die
Politik in der Energieversorgung nichts
mehr zu suchen hat und dass das alles
privatisiert wurde übrigens nicht mit
Stimmen der SPD und das mal zu sagen und
das Ergebnis war das hat Herr Habeck wie
ich finde in den letzten Wochen zurecht
kritisiert dass die Politik überhaupt
keine Eingriffsmöglichkeiten mehr hat
und das in der Tat zu einem
Riesengeschäft wurde und ich finde es
gibt einen Punkt vor Illner bei dem die
SPD ich glaube auch darüber hinaus wir
uns fragen müssen wieso haben wir
eigentlich so lange an diese Idee von
wirtschaftlicher Austausch schafft am
Ende Stabilität und Frieden geglaubt ich
glaube da gibt es ich sage das mal für
mich als Sozialdemokraten ich kann nicht
für die SPD insgesamt sprechen und
wahrscheinlich trifft das auch auf
liberale und die Konservativen zu wir
haben eine sehr lange Zeit gedacht wir
Deutschen hätten quasi die Formel dafür
gefunden und wie man Konflikte löst
beginnend in der Entspannungspolitik wie
die Brandts der Fall der des Eisernen
Vorhangs die Zusammenarbeit mit ich
glaube es hat nicht es hat eine eine
Kommentatorin in den letzten Tagen mal
gesagt es gebe eine ziemlich typisch
deutsche arroganzen zu wissen wie man
mit Russland umgeht ich glaube an der
Kritik ist was dran dass wir viel zu
lange Russland verwechselt haben mit der
Sowjetunion die Sowjetunion eine Status
Quo macht mit der man relativ gut
verhandeln konnte und nicht erkannt
haben dass Putin längst zeigt dass er
eine revisionistische macht ist und die
alten Ideen von
wirtschaftlicher Kontakt schafft am Ende
Stabilität bei ihm nicht mehr
funktionieren das ist ein Vorwurf den
sozusagen ich politisch akzeptieren
würde ich würde dann nur sozusagen sagen
den haben nicht nur Sozialdemokraten
gemacht sondern ganz also wenn ich mich
richtig erinnere war seit 2005
und die Bundeswehr ruiniert haben glaube
ich cdu-verteilungsminister das haben
Sie auch schon gesagt jetzt haben Sie
auch schon gesagt wir bleiben fair und
Fragen Marina weißband ob es ein
Netzwerk gab zwischen Politikern und
Putin und Unternehmen in Russland
das weiß ich selbstverständlich nicht
ich weiß nur was öffentlich bekannt ist
als Bürgerin und ich meine es ist
ziemlich öffentlich bekannt wie stark
die Verstrickungen zwischen Gazprom und
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern immer waren was
ich weiß ist dass ich 2014 geschrieben
habe wir müssen jetzt Putin mit allen
zivilen Mitteln aufhalten denn das wird
sonst immer teurer und danach und ich
habe ja kein Geheimwissen ich habe keine
Geheimdienste ich habe nur das ich habe
nur aufgepasst danach wurde Nord Stream
2 beschlossen danach haben Sie Herr
Gabriel meines Wissens 2016 erlaubt dass
russische Unternehmer einen guten Teil
unserer Gasspeicher kaufen
RWE idea das haben sie genehmigt da
hatte die Politik durchaus macht drüber
sie hätten sagen können nein das ist zu
viel Konzentration das macht uns zu
abhängig das haben sie damals
ausgeschlagen es ist nicht so dass die
Politik keine Gestaltungsmacht hatte es
ist so dass damals die ganze Zeit über
Putin sehr stark das misshandelns in die
Hand gelegt wurde es wurde die ganze
Zeit behauptet dass sein
privatwirtschaftliche Initiativen noch
im Februar diesen Jahres hat Kevin
Kühnert behauptet Nord streamsweise eine
privatwirtschaftliche Initiative und wir
sollten nicht darüber reden und jetzt
legen wir Putin wieder das Heft des
Handelns in die Hand indem wir uns nicht
am Völkerrecht richten was ein
Kriegseintritt wäre und was nicht indem
wir sagen die Lieferung schwerer Waffen
ist kein Kriegseintritt völkerrechtlich
machen wir uns damit nicht so
Kriegspartei wir müssen nichts
befürchten sondern wir überlassen es
Putin das zu entscheiden und ja das
sieht für mich ehrlich gesagt nach
Netzwerken aus zumindest wünsche ich mir
da Aufklärung oder klarere Kommunikation
das wäre sehr sehr wichtig wir Gegenrede
Herr Gabriel hätten sie diese
Gasspeicher nicht besser nicht verkaufen
sollen an Gazprom
vom Rathaus kommt ist man immer schlauer
wir haben das damals gemacht weil wir
Überzeugung waren dass wir mit Russland
einen stabilen Lieferanten haben der das
nicht einsetzen wird zur Erpressung der
Europäischen Union war genau das die
Erfahrung mit der Sowjetunion war die in
dunkelsten Zeiten des Kalten Krieges
immer geliefert hat und dass das ein
Fehler war ich meine das ist ja nur ganz
offensichtlich die Frage ist nur ist das
ursächlich für diesen Krieg und das
finde ich ehrlich gesagt ein starkes
Stück das zu behaupten und
Netzwerke ich meine die Formulierung von
Herrn Melnik der deutsche
Bundespräsident hätte einen Spinnennetz
für russische Interessen gewoben er
nennt Sozialdemokraten Kumpane das ist
ja ein Begriff aus sozusagen der
Kriminologie Banditen sind Kumpane das
finde ich alles eine Art und Weise mit
dem Land umzugehen und seinen
Repräsentanten die jedenfalls nicht
angemessen ist angemessen an dem was
Deutschland nicht nur jetzt sondern seit
2014 für die Ukraine gemacht können wir
aber trotzdem noch mal bei Putin bleiben
und sagen dieser Putin von heute nach
allem was ansonsten geschehen ist dieser
Putin von heute ist offensichtlich ein
Barbar das ist offensichtlich ein
Politiker der einen Volk nicht nur sein
Selbstbestimmungsrecht abspricht sondern
es dahin morchelt sie haben selber sehr
klug und sehr schnell nach dem Beginn
dieses Krieges gesagt dass europäische
die europäische Friedensordnung ist
zerstört der Eiserne Vorhang wird
wiederkommen wir werden wieder zwei
Machtzentren in der Welt haben das war
eine schnelle und wahrscheinlich leider
zutreffende Analyse dann schließt sich
die Frage an muss man sich gegenüber
diesem Wladimir Putin nicht anders
verhalten
ja das tun wir jetzt alle wir sind ja
nicht die einzigen die in Europa mit
Russland erdgasgeschäfte gemacht haben
es gibt ja Länder die zu 100 Prozent
davon abhängen übrigens zu Zeiten des
damaligen Bundeskanzlers Helmut Kohl war
glaube ich die Abhängigkeit von
russischen Erdgas ungefähr so hoch wie
heute das heißt da gab es ganz viel
Vertrauen in ein Land das in seiner
politischen Führung kein Vertrauen
verdient hat und das ändert sich ja
jetzt dramatisch die Frage ist gibt es
eigentlich eine Möglichkeit
komplett sich Gesprächen mit Russland
auf Dauer zu verweigern und meine Sorge
ist dass für uns Illusionen machen der
Krieg wird nicht vorbei sein die Ukraine
wird sich nicht ergeben auch wenn sie
nicht gewinnt was erfahrt vorhin gesagt
hat ist doch die Sorge darum dass das
Ziel Russland zu besiegen und die
Ukraine zu gewinnen am Ende dazu führt
dass Herr Putin dazu bereit ist auch
Massenvernichtungswaffen von
biologischen bis atomaren Waffen
einzusetzen und seine Sorge ist dass
wenn man das Ziel ausgibt Russland zu
besiegen dass das die Konsequenz sein
wird und diese schwierige Trennungslinie
jetzt zu finden wie weit müssen wir sie
Ukraine unterstützen dass sie nicht
verlieren
aufpassen dass wir ein Budde nicht die
Möglichkeit zu etwas liefern ja das sagt
Frau weißband dass das Völkerrecht das
regelt das Bittere ist vorbei das
entscheidet leider Herr Putin und nicht
das Völkerrecht der Blick ins Gesetzbuch
hilft uns gar nichts sondern leider
müssen wir damit leben dass da wie Frau
immer gesagt hat ein offensichtlich ein
Barbar ist der bereit ist alles zu tun
wenn er vor einer Niederlage steht und
ich habe ein Fahrt so verstanden dass er
davon warnt und ich meine wenn ein
Militär mit der Erfahrung das macht ich
wage mir nicht den mal so aus der Tiefe
meines Gemüts zu widersprechen weil ich
sozusagen der bessere Hobby
militärpolitiker bin ich glaube dass man
das ernst nehmen muss dennoch hat unsere
Verteidigungsbereitschaft ja
offensichtlich enorm gelitten und damit
natürlich auch die
Verteidigungsbereitschaft dieser
Demokratie und der Freiheit im Westen
Herr Kiesewetter ich kann Ihnen und
möchte Ihnen die Frage natürlich auch
nach Frau Merkel nicht ersparen es gibt
Menschen die haben das Wirken auch von
ihr ausführlich verfolgt und die sagen
mit 2016 und dem in Angriff nehmen von
Nord Stream 2 mit 2008 und Ukraine nein
Georgien nein in die Nato hat sie im
Grunde Putin noch die viel größeren
Geschenke in den Schoß gelegt also was
sagt da der aus dem Politiker also
zunächst mal geht es nicht darum
Russland zu besiegen sondern es geht
darum dass die Ukraine gewinnen kann
Russland können wir nicht besiegen aber
diesen Krieg muss die Ukraine gewinnen
und die Fehler die sind ja sehr deutlich
geworden in der etwas verschminkelten
Rhetorik gerade die sind in der
Vergangenheit gemacht worden es war der
Wirtschaftsminister Gabriel der nicht
dafür gesorgt hat dass nordstream 2 auf
europäischer Ebene gehandelt wird und es
war die Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel
die auch erst lange Jahre gesagt hat
Nord Stream 2 ist ein
privatwirtschaftliches Projekt was
definitiv falsch war unser Fraktions
hat ja sehr klar gesagt am letzten
Wochenende in der Frankfurter
Allgemeinen Zeitung wir werden das
Aufarbeiten auch wir als Union müssen
hier unsere Hausaufgaben machen aber wir
dürfen jetzt nicht ablenken es geht
darum dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg
gewinnt und dass wir natürlich Fehler
gemacht haben in der Vergangenheit warum
wurde es nicht als europäisches Projekt
behandelt
mir fällt gerade ein dass Frau Merkel ja
noch verhindert hat dass die
us-fraktionen überhaupt wirken das hat
ja jetzt nicht nur Frau Schwesig gemacht
da hat sie sich ja massive eingesetzt
ist völlig richtig weil natürlich die
Sanktionen die damals ich war seinerzeit
in USA gewesen vom US-Kongress verhängt
werden sollten im September 2019
natürlich unfair sind wenn man sich
selber untereinander schwächt aber es
zeigt ja was für ein Alleingang
Deutschland damals gegangen ist in
welcher Überheblichkeit die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland eine
Energiepolitik gegen Polen gegen das
Baltikum am Anfang auch gegen die
Ukraine Herr Gabel hat ja geschildert
wie es dann geheilt wurde gemacht hat
und ein macron hat er von Deutschland
die Unterstützung Nord Stream 2 dadurch
abverhandelt in dem im Aachen Auftrag
dann eine militärische beistandsklausel
Deutschlands mit eingefügt wurde also
wir haben ja erst Jahre später diesen
Fehler
korrigiert und die haben unsere
europäischen Nachbarn übrigens typiert
damit und haben jetzt natürlich auch
wieder eine Bestätigung dafür wie groß
eigentlich deren Misstrauen ist
vielleicht können wir
deswegen ist ja der Punkt so wichtig
dass Olaf Scholz nicht beliebig
erscheint sondern dass er sich ganz klar
an der Seite der Ukraine und derjenigen
Staaten der Europäischen Union und
nato-positioniert die massiv
unterstützen und ich glaube da kann Olaf
Scholz noch mehr machen dass wir als
Union auch aufarbeiten müssen völlig
klar es wird nicht nur einen
Untersuchungsausschuss in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern geben das ist
wahrscheinlich auch klar und vielleicht
können wir noch mal mit Blick nach vorne
fragen was Frau major für die nächste
Zeit jetzt entscheidend ist ist es
richtig und ist es wichtig dass wir uns
um diese Abstimmung in Hintergrund mit
den anderen NATO-Partnern an dieser
Stelle kümmern darauf haben sie vorhin
schon hingewiesen wie geschwächt ist dir
der Bundeskanzler wie sehr hat unser
Ansehen jetzt schon gelitten und was
muss getan werden damit sich das ändert
ganze Sack voll Fragen ja sagen wir nur
den wie sehr hat unser Image gelitten in
der letzten Zeit das ist glaube ich noch
mal eine gute Gelegenheit um auf Nummer
ganz ganz kurzen Schritt zurückzugehen
2014 hätte ein Weckruf sein können und
viele von unseren Mittel- und
osteuropäischen Partnern die auch
Roderich käsewetter eben erwähnte für
die wir gern der große anlehnpartner
sind die baltischen Staaten und Polen
haben uns spätestens seit 2014 gesagt
Russland ist kein konstruktiver Akteur
mehr und wir wollten das nicht hören
oder teilte der Bundesregierung wollten
das nicht hören das heißt das heißt wir
hatten eine ziemlich lange Lernphase bis
jetzt Nord Stream 2 genauso